تحدث الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن
احتمال اطلاقه عمليه بريه تركيه في سوريا
ضد الاكراد الهدف الثار لمقتل اثنين من
المواطنين اثرها هجمات صاروخيه اطلقت من
منطقه كوباني
تهديدات تقلق المجتمع الدولي في الولايات
المتحده قالت انها تعرض اي عمل عسكري
يزعزع استقرار الوضع في سوريا
[موسيقى]
على انقره الامتناع عن استخدام القوه
العسكريه المفرطه في سوريا اما باريس فقد
دعت لضغط النفس
حول هذا الموضوع معنى الان من اسطنبول
مراسلنا حسين اسد حسين كما راينا اذا عده
دول وزينا روسيا والولايات المتحده وفرنسا
تدعو الى ضبط النفس وتبدي معارضه صريحه او
مبطنه لاي تدخل تركي في سوريا لكن من جانب
تركيا هل التحضيرات جاريه لعمليه كهذه
ربيع هذه التصريحات والمواقف الغربيه
سمعناها كانت تسبق وترافق العمليات
العسكريه التركيه السابقه ولكنها لم تغير
شيئا على الارض عندما تقرر انقره ان تبدا
التواغل البري في شمال السوري فانها تبدا
ذلك وتقول ان المساله مساله امن قومي ولا
نستاذن احدا للدفاع عن امن حدودنا
ومواطننا هذه المره الحديث عن انتقام
للاعتداء الذي وقع في اسطنبول وهذا ما دفع
القوه التركيه الى ضربات الجويه وهذا ما
تسعى وسائل اعلام وقربه من الحكومه لتحشيد
الراي العام لدعم العمليه من خلاله عندما
نرى هنا في صحيفه اقسام ربيع وهي صحيفه
مقربه من الحكومه همم وقت الحساب وهنا همم
الهجمات التي
نفذتيه للرد على الهجوم الدنيء الذي
استهدف مدينه اسطنبول وبالتالي هذا ما
تذهب اليه وسائل الاعلام مقربه من الحكومه
اردوغان استبعد ان تقتصر هذه العمليه على
الضربات الجويه وقال ان هناك مشاورات بشان
القوات البريه التي يمكن ان همم تشارك في
عمليه بريه في مرحله مقبله وعلى هذا
الاساس ذهب وزير الدفاع خلص يا كار مساء
امس الى ما قرا عمليات القوات البريه بعد
ان تلقى تعليمات جديده من الرئيس اردوغان
حسب ما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الدفاع للمره
الاولى تصف العمليه العسكريه المخلب السيف
بالضربات البريه والجويه هي تشير الى
الضربات البريه للمره الاولى ما يعني ان
هناك استعدادات حقيقيه سواء في اجانب
التركي القوه التي تصل باستمرار الى
المنطقه الحدوديه وايضا بالنسبه للقوات
الترك المتواجده على الارض فعليا في مناطق
شمالي سوريا وايضا بالنسبه لفصال المعارضه
المدعومه من انقره الكل مستعد للبدء بهذا
التوغل البري الواسع ولكن لانقرا تريد
تجنب الخسائر المتوقعه لهذا التوغل
باعتبار انه يستهدف الحصن الاخير
للمقاتلين الاكراد فانها تكثف ضربات
الجويه والقذف المدفعي للتمهيد للتواغل
البري في مرحله مقبله
معك طبعا تطورات الوضع اولمبي اول شكرا
جزيلا